[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello this is lemony snicket
and for some reason i'm going to read
out loud chapter 2
of this very distinguished and yet
utterly terrifying book
by neil gaiman chapter 2
the next day it had stopped raining but
a thick white fog
had lowered over the house i'm going for
a walk
said coraline don't go too far said her
mother and dress up warmly
coraline put on her blue coat with a
hood her red scarf and her yellow
wellington boots she went out
miss [ __ ] was walking her dogs hello
caroline
said miss [ __ ] rotten weather yes
said coraline i played porsche once
said miss [ __ ] miss forcible talks
about herophilia but it was my porsche
they came to see
when we trod the boards miss pink was
bundled up in pullovers and cardigans
so she seemed more small and circular
than ever
she looked like a large fluffy egg she
wore thick glasses that made her eyes
seem huge
they used to send flowers to my dressing
room they did she said
who did asked coraline miss fink looked
around cautiously
looking over first one shoulder and then
over the other peering into the mists
as though she someone might be listening
men she whispered then she tugged the
dogs to heal and waddled off back toward
the house
coraline continued her rock she was
three quarters of the way around the
house when she saw miss forcible
standing at the door of the flat she
shared with miss pink
have you seen miss pink caroline
coraline told her that she had and that
miss [ __ ] was out walking the dogs
i do hope she doesn't get lost it'll
bring on her shingles if she does you'll
see you said miss forcible
you'd have to be an explorer to find
your way out around in this fog
i'm an explorer said coraline
of course you are lovey said miss
forcible don't get lost now
coraline continued walking through the
gardens and the gray mist
she always kept her kept in sight of the
house
after about 10 minutes of walking she
found herself back where she had started
the hair over her eyes was limp and wet
and her face felt damp
ahoy caroline called the crazy old man
upstairs
oh hello said coraline she could hardly
see the old man through the mist
he walked down the steps on the outside
of the house that led up past coraline's
front door
to the door of his flat he walked down
very slowly
coraline waited at the bottom of the
stairs
the mice do not like the mist he told
her
it makes their whiskers droop i don't
like the mist much either at emitted
coraline
the old man leaned down so close that
the bottoms of his mustache tickled
coraline's ear
the mice have a message for you he
whispered
coraline didn't know what to say the
message is this
don't go through the door he paused
does that mean anything to you no said
coraline
the old man shrugged they are funny the
mice they get things wrong
they got your name wrong you know they
keep saying coraline
not caroline not caroline at all
he picked up a milk bottle from the
bottom of the stairs and started back up
to his attic flat
coraline went indoors her mother was
working in her study
her mother's study smelled of flowers
what shall i do ask coraline
when do you go back to school asked her
mother next week
said coraline said her mother i suppose
i shall have to get your new school
clothes remind me dear or else i'll
forget
and she went back to typing things on
the computer screen
what shall i do repeated coraline draw
something
her mother passed her a sheet of paper
and a ballpoint pen
coraline tried drawing the mist after 10
minutes of drawing she still had a white
paper with
m i s t written on it in one corner in
slightly wiggly letters
she grunted and passed it to her mother
mmm
very modern dear said coraline's mother
coraline crept into the drawing room and
tried to open her the old door in the
corner
it was locked once more she supposed her
mother must have locked it again she
shrugged coraline went to see her father
he had us back to the door as he typed
go away he said cheerfully as she walked
in
i'm bored she said learn how to tap
dance he suggested without turning
around
coraline shook her head why don't you
play with me she asked
busy he said working he added he still
hadn't turned around to look at her
why don't you go and bother miss pink
and miss forcible
coraline put on her coat and pulled up
her hood and went out of the house
she went downstairs she rang the door of
miss [ __ ] and miss forcible's flat
coraline could hear a frenzied woofing
as the scotty dogs ran out into the hall
after a while miss [ __ ] opened the door
oh it's you caroline she said
angus hammesh bruce down now lovies it's
only caroline
come in dear would you like a cup of tea
the flat smell to furniture polish and
dogs
yes please said coraline miss pink let
her into a dusty little room which she
called the parlor
on the walls were black and white
photographs of pretty women and theater
programs and frames
miss forcible was sitting in one of the
armchairs knitting hard
they poured coraline a cup of tea in a
little pink bone china cup with a saucer
they gave her a dry garibaldi biscuit to
go with it
miss forcible looked at miss pink picked
up her knitting and took a deep breath
anyway april as i was saying you still
have to admit there's life in the old
dog yet
miriam dear neither of us is as young as
we were
madame akarti replied miss forcible the
nurse and romeo
lady bracknell character parts they
can't retire you from the stage
now miriam we agreed said miss pink
carline wondered if she'd forgotten she
was there
they weren't making much sense she
decided they were having an argument as
old
and comfortable as an armchair the kind
of argument that no one really ever
really wins or loses
which can go on forever if both parties
are willing
she sipped her tea i'll read the leaves
if you want said miss pink to coraline
sorry said coraline the tea leaves dear
i'll read your future
coraline past miss spanker cup miss pink
peered short-sightedly at the black
leaves in the bottom
she pursed her lips
you know caroline she said after a while
you're in terrible danger
[Music]
you know caroline she said after a while
you're in
terrible danger miss forcible snorted
and put down her knitting don't be silly
april stop staring the girl
scaring the girl your eyes are going
pass me that cop child
coraline carried the cop over to miss
forcible miss forcible looked into it
carefully
shook her head and looked into it again
oh dear she said you were right april
she is in danger
see miriam said miss bunk triumphantly
my eyes were as good as they ever were
what am i in danger from
ask coraline mrs [ __ ] and forcible
stared at her blankly
it didn't say said miss pink tea leaves
aren't reliable for that kind of thing
not really they're good for general
but not for specifics what should i do
then
ask coraline who is slightly alarmed by
this
don't wear green in your dressing room
suggested miss pink
or mention the scottish play adam miss
forcible
coraline wondered why so few of the
adults she had met made any sense
she sometimes wondered who they thought
they were talking to
and be very very careful said miss pink
she got it from the armchair and went
over to the fireplace on the mantelpiece
was a small
jar and miss [ __ ] took off the top of
the jar and began to pull things out of
it
there was a tiny china duck a thimble
a strange brass coin two paper clips and
a stone with a hole in it
she passed coraline the still stone with
a hole in it
what's it for askcoreline the hole went
all the way through the middle of the
stone
she held it up to the window and looked
through it it might help said miss pink
they're good for bad things sometimes
coraline put on her coat and said
goodbye to mrs [ __ ] and forcible into
the dogs and went
outside the mist hung like blindness
around the house
she walked slowly to the stairs up to
her family's flat
and then stopped and looked around in
the mist it was a ghost world
in danger thought coraline to herself it
sounded exciting
it didn't sound like a bad thing not
really coraline went upstairs
her fist closed tightly around her new
stone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you